MAN: First verse.
Roll cameras, please.
On this one, let's do something
where they start here.
-Start here?
-Yeah.
ANTHONY MANDLER:
We're taking established artists
and we're pulling them
into the Game of Thrones world.
The show establishes
all these different kingdoms.
I wanted to integrate
the color palettes
of winter and Khaleesi
with today's biggest stars.
♪ Heavy is the crown ♪
MANDLER: Abel wanted
the Jon Snow-esque character.
SZA would sort of take
the Khaleesi.
With Travis, it was about
finding a combination
of those two powerhouses.
♪ The knife in my heart
It couldn't slow me down ♪
-♪ 'Cause power is power ♪
♪ The fire never goes out ♪
♪ I rise from my scars
Nothing hurts me now ♪
MANDLER: I'm a super
Game of Thrones fan.
I'm here just to sit in
the throne for a little while.